[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale et régionale tout de
suite les titres de ce mardi 30 avril et
demain c'est le 1er mai jour de la fête
du travail un moment aussi pour acheter
du muguet parmi les vendeurs notamment
les militants du parti communiste
français action importante pour le
mouvement politique afin de financer la
production de tracts et d'affichés en
cette période de campagne électorale
invité de ce journal ibrahim attal de la
cgt des yvelines le syndicat appelle à
un rassemblement massif contre les
urgences sociales pour ce 1er mai
faut-il pour autant une convergence des
luttes avec les gilet jaune qui ont
prévu également de se mobiliser et nous
lui poserons la question
enfin retour sur la 4e édition du salon
du salon saveurs et jardins 1800
personnes se sont rendues à cet
événement le week-end dernier au château
de néville à gambais gastronomie du
terroir étaient notamment au programme
pour commencer ce projet d'attentât d'y
jouer dont vous avez sûrement entendu
parler
hier quatre personnes dont un mineur de
17 ans a été interpellé vendredi et sont
toujours entendus par la direction
générale de la sécurité intérieure et
d'après une information de nos confrères
de m6 certains de ces individus ont été
arrêtés dans le centre et l'est des
yvelines ils préparaient une attaque
visant les forces de l'ordre sur le
territoire les quatre hommes cherchaient
à se procurer des armes pour un passage
à l'acte semble-t-il imminent et demain
c'est le 1er mai symbole de cette
journée le muguet la plante est vendue
principalement par les fleuristes mais
aussi par le parti communiste français
et vous allez le voir dans ce reportage
de calypso vanier c'est un moment est
stratégique pour le mouvement politique
nicole pradier milite pour le parti
communiste depuis 1974
et pour elle la fête du muguet c'est
sacré c'est vraiment une vente militante
c'est à dire que ce n'est pas on vend
pas une fleur comme on irait en acheter
chez le fleuriste mais ça vraiment une
signification de mu
de lutte des travailleurs dans le monde
entier
secrétaire de section de conflent elle
est venue récupérer des plantes à
clochette pour les vendre le 1er mai
près des centres commerciaux prix d'un
pot de muguet 8 à 10 euros
une ressource importante pour le parti
qui a réalisé un score de moins de 3 %
aux dernières élections législatives en
une journée on est capable de faire
entre 2 et 3000 euros de bénéfices ce
qui nous permet à la fédération de
pouvoir en même temps souscrire pour la
liste de ian brossât parce qu'on est en
campagne électorale et en même temps de
pouvoir vivre tout au long de l'année 15
à 20 % moyenne des recettes annuelles
c'est ce que rapportent les vente de
muguet au bureau du parti communiste des
yvelines l'argent récolté permet de
diffuser des tracts des affiches ou de
promouvoir le journal l'humanité
investissements donc stratégique
d'autant que cette action militante
touche un large public un avantage est
loin d'être anodin à un mois des
élections européennes
et justement ce 1er mai seront mobilisés
également les syndicats et pour
continuer à parler de cette thématique
ibrahima talent est avec mon plateau
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes membre de la
direction de l'union départementale de
la cgt des yvelines le syndicat qui
appelle par la voix de son secrétaire
général philippe martinez je cite tout
le monde à se mobiliser pourquoi c'est
toujours un moment important pour vous
cette journée de mobilisation cette
journée du 1er mai oui c'est une journée
importante pour nous parce que c'est là
que nous travailleurs dans toutes les
entreprises doivent revendiquer dénoncer
certaines conditions de travail
revendiquer l'augmentation des salaires
d'accord mais aussi dénoncer certaines
situations telles que certains
travaillent dans des conditions pénibles
difficile des fois même à l'absence de
certaines protections comme dans le btp
donc ce sont des c'est une c'est une
journée que vraiment nous travailleurs
on doit sortir manifester et revendiquer
pour notre pour plus de doigts
alors justement philippe martinez appel
à une mobilisation massive pour un
changement de cap radical de la
politique gouvernementale vous parliez
des quelques urgence les principales
d'urgence aujourd'hui en matière sociale
quelles sont elles
oui c'est c'est l'augmentation des
salaires pour le pouvoir d'achat donc
aussi est également devait faire reculer
certaines certaines point que nous
sommes tout à fait contre qui remet en
cause ce que nous avions gagné déjà
n'est donc nous devons être sur le
terrain pour effectivement à dire non ça
suffit et puis voilà plus de droits plus
de justice pour nous on est à la fin
justement du grand débat national avec
ses annonces des manuels macron sur le
pouvoir d'achat notamment va les voir à
l'image la baisse de 5 milliards d'euros
d impôt sur le revenu à partir de 2020
réindexation également des retraites en
dessous de 2000 euros une annonce aussi
pour les pensions alimentaires un pays
qui serait directement prélevée par les
caisses d'allocations familiales est ce
que ces quelques annonces suffisent pas
du tout comment vous avez réagi suite à
ces annonces le président de la
république a encore une fois réaffirmé
sa volonté obstinée de maintenir
vraiment une politique juste moneo
profite depuis
fortuné donc il va pas assez loin sur
sur ses besoins à rire il n'a rien
absolument rien dit en ce qui concerne
l'augmentation des salaires
donc ça c'est encore une fois il d'un
mois il démontre vraiment son refus
d'entendre la forte exigence qui est
exprimé par les mobilisations
donc concernant la fonction publique
nous avons nous avons vu un gouvernement
qui se place sur la défensive sous la
pression des luttes c'est un set au
moratoire quand même sur toutes les
fermetures les fermetures des écoles des
hôpitaux des lits dédie donc sur sur
l'a62 les suppressions de postes donc
nous la saisie des satisfactions ce que
tu nous l'as saint etienne nous
demandons vraiment occupe au recrutement
massive dans la fonction publique mais
également l'augmentation de la valeur du
point d'indicé est effectivement à dire
le retrait du projet de loi du soft qui
est une atteinte aux garanties
démocratiques qui font de la fonction
publique donc juste pour terminer
ibrahim établissent que l'entretien
avance pour la première fois en tout cas
pour ce 1er mai il y aura également la
mobilisation des gilet jaune qui sont
mobilisés depuis novembre sur le
territoire du coup de main est ce qu'il
faut une convergence des luttes sente
qu'elle souhaite philippe martinez il a
appelé à défiler côte à côte et pas
séparément chacun de son côté ce que
c'est c'est ce qu'il faut faire demain
il faut cette convergence ou et dom à
demain c'est de toute façon c'est
l'étrave nous sommes des travailleurs
avant tout donc des travailleurs vent
demain
manifestez manifester effectivement
contre la politique du gouvernement qui
est aussi le choix des entreprises mais
aussi cessé de dénoncer les conditions
de travail des intérimaires qui occupent
les postes les plus pénibles dangereux
mais également le train on va dire que
le travail doit être reconnu que le
travail soit 1 ne soient pas pénalisés
donc notamment le travail au noir
nous appelons également à la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers
donc ça c'est demain et toutes ces
thématiques le fait d'être à côté des
gilet jaune d'avoir une mobilisation
climatique ça peut être davantage
présent à voir voilà un point plus fort
en tout cas pour faire face au
gouvernement
effectivement face au gouvernement c'est
pour cela que la cgt appelle avec
d'autres organisations syndicales à une
grosse mobilisation unitaire le 9 mai
donc pour la fonction publique c'est
pour revendiquer effectivement plus de
personnel mais aussi il y aura des
rassemblements à la sous-préfecture de
mantes-la-jolie en rassemblement à
l'agencé régionale de la santé à
versailles mais également devant la
préfecture de versailles
donc pour les effectivement c'est le
moment de descendre sur le terrain
effectivement la cgt a également appelé
le 14 mai pour une caravane des
retraités qui partira de rambouillet
passe un parent trap pour fusionner pour
les prochains rendez-vous de la cgt
effectivement donc nous demain on sera à
paris manifester en tant que travailleur
donc tout le travail sont les bienvenus
merci ibrahima sall d'être passé sur ce
plateau pour parler de ce 1er mai je
rappelle que vous êtes membre de la
direction de l'union départementale de
la cgt 78 les élections européennes
approchent elles se tiendront le
dimanche 26 mai prochain et en vue du
scrutin suite de nos questions aux
candidats ce soir c'est l'eurodéputé
socialiste sortant éric andrieu qui se
prêtent au jeu les positionner en
cinquième place tu place sur la liste du
ps ces réponses sont recueillis par
michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
c'est la seule liste qui associe de
façon aussi prégnante les citoyens à la
représentation citoyenne française
et puis la liste s'appelle en vie
d'europe écologique et sociale ce qui
montre bien que la question de l'enjeu
européen est présent dans les
fondamentaux de notre vision est ensuite
que la question de l'écologie et le
social sont indissociables du projet
comportements n'ont absolument pas le ps
a depuis le début avec tasse public et
nouvelle donne appelé au rassemblement
de la gauche
aujourd'hui les radicaux de gauche et de
vous rejoindre et le contenu
programmatique est terminée puisque
l'avion et commune sur cet enjeu là d'un
équilibre entre eux la notion d'économie
d'écologie et de social non je pense que
c'est un moment historique pour le parti
socialiste français comme il a été en
comme il a été en 1929 et 69 en
particulier et que aujourd'hui c'est une
question de renaissance avec l'enjeu de
remettre au coeur du débat politique les
valeurs du socialisme celle de l'égalité
celle de la fraternité bien sûr mais
également de l'équité de la justice
sociale de la redistribution et de la
régulation
[Musique]
et vous retrouvez l'ensemble de ces
modules avec les candidats eux
européenne sur notre site internet tv 78
ans comme vigilance santé les
responsables de la propagation de la zes
de la dengue du ycca ou encore du
chikungunya le moustique tigre et
s'installe durablement en ile-de-france
est d'après cette carte du ministère de
la santé les yvelines sont même placés
en niveau orange quand d'autres
départements voisins comme l'essonne
sont au rouge pour se protéger éliminé
régulièrement les eaux stagnantes dans
votre habitation
équipez-vous si besoin de pièges ou de
spirales anti-moustiques et vous pouvez
à signaler la présence de cet insecte
sur le portail de l'ansès le week end
dernier se déroulait la quatrième
édition du salon saveurs et jardins à
gambais une soixantaine d'exposants a
fait le déplacement au château de
neuville reportage de manon varades
malgré un temps capricieux la quatrième
édition du salon saveurs et jardins
organisée par l'association la voix de
gambe et se tenait au château de
neuville habituellement fermés au public
en dehors des journées du patrimoine
qu'on essaye de faire c'est de faire
quelque chose qui touche au niveau du
jardin étant vestimentaire parce que
vous allez pouvoir voir un chapelier
enfin une personne qui vendait des
chapeaux on essaye de toucher un petit
peu le jardin par toutes ses formes et
après il ya la gastronomie une
soixantaine d'exposants étaient présents
avec notamment des producteurs locaux
sur mon ce temps je propose la vente de
viande charolaise qui est conditionnée
sous vide
alors aujourd'hui je ferai de la viande
direct individuellement enfin petit
paquet un peu plus loin située dans la
vallée de la vaucouleurs la pisciculture
de ville est installé depuis 1896 autour
d'un moulin à eau
participez également au salon alors ce
qu'on propose
ce sont des rillettes et des terrines de
poisson à base de saumon fumé et de
truite fumée
vous avez également du saumon fumé qui
vient decosse
transformer chez nous donc on le salon
le fume et je vais trancher à la
gastronomie produits du jardin
conférence 1800 passants ont déambulé et
tout le week-end dans les allées du
salon saveurs et jardins qu'on habite à
la campagne pour nous c'est l'occasion
d'allier la proximité de tous les
commerçants de la région de pouvoir
allier aussi à la fois la gastronomie et
puis bah tout ce qui est fleurs et
potagers et en fait ces deux centres
d'intérêts puis c'était surtout
l'occasion de faire une sortie en
famille le prochain rendez vous est fixé
l'année prochaine toujours au château de
neuville le dernier week-end d'avril
avec tous le même souhait une météo plus
clémente
avant de se quitter attention si vous
empruntez le rer b au départ de saint
rémy les chevreuse à partir de demain et
jusqu'à samedi inclus
le trafic sera interrompu entre les
gares de massy palaiseau et de
bourg-la-reine des travaux de
modernisation seront effectués en vue
notamment de la création d'un centre de
maintenance à massy et des bus de
substitution seront mis en place et 250
agents de la ratp spécialement mobilisés
pour cette période
voilà c'est la fin du set 8 journal
c'est à revoir sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile l'info
locale revient en direct jeudi avec
wilfrid richier dans un instant vous
retrouver mélanie poquet pour l'émission
7,8 culture belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]